[Music]
hello YouTube chess Louis and my friends
this is grunge in here welcome to the
15th episode of my dirty chess tricks
against Sicilian in this episode I'm
going to show you a nice tricky line in
the classical setup of the Sicilian
Najdorf edition from the white
perspective the opening arises after the
following model E for C Phi Knight to f3
d6 d4 C captures d4 Knight captures d4
Knight to f6 attacking on e4 Knight to
c3 defending and now the characteristic
Nozdormu a6 which not only stop the
intrusion of any white pieces but later
on black can expand with the move b5 and
gain some space on the Queen side ok the
classical setup start with the move
Bishop to e2 so as you can see I have
highlighted by the arrows very simple
but effective plan of the campaign by
wide he wants to castle on the Kings
side play the move f4 and the move
Bishop to e3 and get a very good King
side attack we will follow the main line
for a while black plays the movie 6
White Castle on the Kings side
Bishop to e7 so now black is all set to
castle on the Kings side and accordingly
why should play the boom f4 and if
allowed then definitely if I will be on
the car so black needs to stop it with
Queen to c7 and now white continues with
Bishop to e3
as you can see black has plenty of
choices amongst them if you open and
continues with castle on the Kings side
or the move Knight to c6 then I strongly
insist you to look out the theory
section as in this video we are going
to concentrate on the moon b phi which
is in fact a modern mu recommended by
many strong engine and if we check this
position in online database you will
find out that there are more than 300
games played from this position well yes
indeed this mu looks so attractive
except there is one problem that black
is instantly losing after playing this
more you won't believe me right but
after watching this video and looking at
my analysis you will literally pray that
you open and play the movie Phi this is
that much dangerous for the black ok
then let's start the ball rolling why
it's fireworks start with E Phi so this
pawn is attacking the knight and in fact
Black has the only good option in this
position is D captures ePHI however in
one blitz game my opponent tried to move
the knight Knight to D Phi but then my
forcing analysis give him the instant
losing position white plays pawn
captures d6 Bishop captures d6 Knight
captures D Phi pawn captures D Phi
Bishop to f3 attacking on D Phi Bishop
to b7 defending and now the star mu
might do a Phi and white has created
multiple threats which cannot be dealt
easily in the game my opponent tried to
move castle on the Kings side but after
the move Queen to d4 it is very obvious
that black is losing the game just
within 50 boos the only move
Epic's has been tried but now you can
see the problem in the black camp yup
very simple Bishop captures D Phi and
now it doesn't matter whether black
captured the bishop or run away
let's say in the game my opponent try
the move King to h8 but after Bishop
captures b7 white emerged with an extra
piece and in fact are very easy to play
position so it is very obvious that here
black has to accept this pawn so D
captures Aoife is forced after that
white will recapture the pawn and in
this position black has namely four
options left
amongst them Knight F to d7 is probably
the highest Lee played more in this
position but we should see what happens
if you opponent try the other news the
first move I want to look at is Knight 2
g8 which looks bit passive but still
black is hoping that he can hold on to
this position but not he cannot as White
has this dazzling sacrifice my captors
b5 ah ahaha well already black is behind
in development and on top of everything
he is a pawn down so the only hope left
is grab this piece and hope that
something is going to work out but in
fact now I'd reveals the whole point
behind sacrificing a piece he can
deliver this check and after black block
the check with any of the move let's say
Bishop to d7 White has this little reply
went to f3 and at least white will get
an exchange in this variation the second
more I want to consider is Knight to d5
which looks more natural in this
position but once again it leads to
instant disaster for the black camp
after Knight captures d5 pawn captures
defy and now the star move
yup it's Knight captures b5 once again
and after pawn captures be fire and this
time around we have Queen
defy and more or less same story as per
class tradition well some of you are
already wondering what happens if Queen
captures Aoife which is in fact the
third bad option for the black as after
the move Bishop to a four black queen
has the only space layer but it looks
quite good as after Queen to see if I
after all black is spinning overnight
well guess what here the fun start with
Bishop to f3 so we are attacking
two-piece and black has very limited
options left in this position the first
obvious response Knight to d5 obviously
fails because of the simple tactic
Knight captures d5 pawn captures defy
and now the nice deflecting move p4 if
Queen captures before then Bishop to
defy and black is going to lose a piece
so black has to keep supporting defy an
only good way to do it is to play Queen
to c4 but nevertheless after rook to
even wiped his tecnique the move Bishop
to d6 something which black needs to
look out immediately and if he now plays
the move Queen to b4 which looks like
pairing the threat but there comes push
up to defy and losing a piece is
unavoidable probably the most critical
line at this position is rook to e7
sacrificing the knight blacks idea is
after white capture denied he wants to
play rook to d7 and gain the piece back
now before I move on I like you to pause
this video and find out how actually
white can save the piece
okay are you confident enough let's see
do you manage to keep your piece the
first move is very obvious Knight to e2
supporting the night and when black
plays the obvious move e5 which looks
like indeed winning of piece but why it
has this nice move in the sleeve before
our old friend which reflects the Queen
point is whether you take the pawn or
move away let's say Queen to b6 then
even though it looks like both the white
pieces are hanging just one move Bishop
to e5 and magically white is saving his
piece after all the complications so
considering all the options let's see
the most critical response here Knight
f2 d7 and at first sight this move looks
very obvious black is attacking twice on
e5 and there is not a good way to defend
this pawn well
chess is a game of surprise and actually
here White has specially invited black
to go into this position as he has a
wonderful winning shot which in fact
wins the game on the spot before I show
it to you I like you to pause this video
and find out a move which instantly give
white of winning position well I hope
you find this wonderful blow boom the
first time when I say this move I said
wah ha
what a move the most interesting part
about rook captures f7 is if you turn on
any engine it will not show this move
instantly but after the depth of 90 not
t-this move suddenly start coming on the
top so this can be used as a great
surprise weapon in Frida to Nimmons as
there are in fact no games from this
position here black more or less obliged
to capture this route as if he continued
with night captures if I then rook
captures g7 is a very strong reply and
queen to if I has the same problem of
fish up to f4 so let's see what is the
idea behind this beautiful rook
sacrifice after the move King captures
Epsilon well first white wants to
deliver this check and now black has
three options of course King cannot go
to f8 due to the simple night II 6 check
and the Queen is a goner
and if the King goes to the g8 then we
have this another dazzling sacrifice in
this position namely Knight to d5
well if black doesn't take this then
we'll take the bishop and then play the
moon Quint we have three so more or less
black is obliged to take the second
piece but after that I think he already
guessed it yes absolutely right
Queen to f3 threatening mate as well as
capture on defy and in fact there is
only one saving resource in this
position Knight to e5 which I'm afraid
not good enough as after Queen captures
defy check King to f8 rook to affranchi
Bishop to f6 and now the winning move
Knight captures b5 bad well it's nothing
but a clear and sacrifice to checkmate
the black King as after pawn captures be
fire Bishop to c5 Queen captures c5 even
though this is not enough to stop the
mage as after Queen capture CF I came to
b8 Queen captures e8 Bishop to d8 and
Queen captures d8
the black baby is strapped in the corner
okay so the force reply is g6 well after
that Queen to f3 check so keeping eye on
the corner rook and once again King has
three options the first smoke King to g7
obviously pretty bad night to e6 getting
the black Queen so that's completely out
of equation if King to g8 then we have
the same pattern Knight to d5 attacking
to piece and funny enough here black
even cannot take this night as after II
kept as defy we have the Queen captures
defy check and now no matter wherever
the King goes let's say King to f8 then
we have this lovely night east six check
which catching the Queen again and again
so the force apply at this point is
black has to play Knight captures ePHI
counter-attack the Queen but the forcing
sequence goes as follows
Knight captures c7 Knight captures f3
with a check and after the move Bishop
to f3 and rook to e7 it seems like black
is an exchange up but this is just time
being as after night to e6 white is
attacking this roof and black rook
doesn't have any square so the best
reply goes in us capture c7 and after
Knight capture c7 after all the
transaction it turns out that white
emerged with a superior twist
development and a clear pawn up probably
the most critical response here by the
black is to play King - eh but after
that White will continue with Knight to
e6 attacking the Queen Queen to e5
attacking to piece
so why responses force white has to play
Bishop to g4
saving both the piece and now indeed
whereas a simple threat Bishop to f4 and
then nabbing the rook in the corner
well I reached this position against a
2300 rated opponent and in this game
my opponent continues wraith-night to b6
safeguarding the rook I played Bishop to
f4 and he continues with Quint web six
never lose the tempo on the Queen so the
obvious response is Knight to e4 and my
opponent plays Queen kept his b2
attacking my rook
okay now we have some forcing sequence I
give him this check he played King to d8
and as my knight is protected on c7 I
decided to save my room with a temple
rook to defend check my opponent blocked
the check with the night
now I regain one of my piece with a
nightcap just ate my opponent captured
my night I played Knight to d6 so as you
can see this move create multiple
threats so by force black has to give up
the bishop so he played Bishop captures
d6
and I simply captured it with my bishop
okay white is attacking the knight so my
happen plays a night to be six and after
Bishop to c5 I think this is a horrible
position for the black even though he's
a piece up currently white is
threatening the move Bishop captures b6
as well as Bishop to d4 and in the game
my opponent played the King to c7 which
turn out as an instant losing move as
after Queen to f4 check Knight to e5 and
now Bishop to b6 which not only regained
the final piece but at the end it will
give this killer punch to two major
pieces and black is completely paralyzed
well I hope you enjoy and learn this
wonderful attacking line in the
classical setup of the nostril variation
remember guys if you open and continue
with Knight F to d7 at this point then
give him this rude shock rook captures
f7 and no matter however black plays he
will get nightmares about this line well
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment and
I'll meet you in my next episode very
soon bye and take care